欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天虽然台股市上涨了270点
不过以整周来说
我们收了一个小黑K
这一周算是涨多反弹之后的压回
而且今天的量只有7000多亿而已
又在缩下来了
大家在等什么呢
可能美国的不确定性比较高
例如公債殖利率昨天压下来
今天又跑上去
油價也始終不上不下的卡在那裡
通紅的遺雲沒有消散
在美國現在成為世界的震樣的時候
我們又遇到了有一些產業上的利空
等一下會來一一幫大家做拆彈
例如聯發科在跌什麼
聯發科在跌谷歌跟麥威爾的合作
像今天整體的PCB從載版起頭往下跌
是因為未知數說要供貨
中國的部分要斷供
這跟台廠什麼關係
为什么现在利空好像反应的比较明显
那接下来下礼拜的布局如何
这是我们每一个礼拜五最重要的一件事
所以等一下欢迎三位来宾来跟大家说分明
第一位是我们的盈利投资中国中 中总
好 中总上个礼拜就有提到
这个礼拜压回的几率非常高
果然出现了压回
但到这边够不够呢
中大胆说他希望还能再下去一些些
这样大家会有更好的买点
尤其今天量能缩到这样的程度
法人都很光旺很稠疚喔
今天涨什么呢
涨塑化航运啊
好这样的情况下如何做操作
他有发现到资金跑到哪里了
高值利率
这个是中大胆的专长喔
等一下帮您讲
盘面上例如今天机体模组开始动了喔
还有一些像塑化股水泥股等等的
到底我们该把资金放到哪里
中大胆有解答喔
好第二位是我们的国家级基金操盘手
黄丰凯凯哥
凯哥今天来刚刚讲的产业性的利空
全部交给他啦
有这个观众朋友问说联发科怎么了
没有怎么了
其实就是麦威尔跟谷歌的合作
事实上不会真的杀伤联发科
等一下告诉你整个ethic的状况
还有今天这个所谓的ABF的薄膜大厂说
他要停工中国一些产能
那我们的载版在叠什么呢
我们的通波机版PCB间叠成一片
所以今天凯哥会来帮您做一个厘清梳理
整体来说对我们台场的PCB是好事
所以等一下来聊咯
好第三位是我们的筹码专家全镇小哥
哥也要说到底航海王有没有回来呢
似曾相似的感觉来咯
这个航海我们有讲
第一天讲还半信半疑
找到今天需要小哥来帮我们解释了
上海集装箱指数已经连八周的上扬了
原来的那些筹码又没有回来
而记忆体跟CPU也帮我们做检验
因为现在记忆体涨到模组去了
小哥今天独家教学
如果发现可转载
但市场所谓的高溢价
愿意花高高的钱去买
后面很有戏
今天有珍贵的表哥要提供给大家
首先有请钟大胆
钟大胆上礼拜就有提醒
这个压回的几率很高
果然是压下来了
但是你有提到
因為量還是相當的辛苦
需要補量
模組這種高值利率的
AI伺服器傳產高值利率的
今天倒是稱盤要有效
是 沒錯
今天終於禮拜五又收紅
好久沒看到禮拜五收紅
所以到底要不要呢
是 我們看市場上今天的一個
比較有利多的部分
就是在外銷的部分
公布的外銷7月份是979億
YLY是61.99%
連續18紅
看起來這個部分應該是還不錯
但為什麼看起來這個盤
市場上就量就很低
然後看起來還好是尾盤
靠著一些全止股把它拉起來
否則今天的整個指數並不是很好看那最主要因素是在於說大家看一下這邊的YY 61.9下個月預估是61.4到64.8
如果你這樣看圖的話
其實它在這個位置就是
下個月就可能會比較偏向走平的
更何況這個月8月份到目前為止
台幣大概是升值快五毛錢
所以相對在這個匯率的部分
營收的估值的YY的部分
可能稍微就會比較偏下
在這個預估的下緣部分
下個月可能會頗千億的部分
到時候下個月再來看
那我們來看一下這個整個市場上
美國的財政財長這邊就四肢
趁一天美債之利率又談回去
我們看下這一波到整個股市
為什麼大家覺得說買起來
會覺得不踏實就是我常提到過
就是道瓊指數這一波是最創新高的
道瓊創新高
如果這邊的拉回是因為科技股
就我們台積電
是因為科技股的上漲
那合理嗎
資金已來這裡
但問題是科技股最近下跌
包括費半
它也可以下跌
那就讓人家會覺得
創新高的
然後類股輪動的話
如果科技股拉回的時候
它竟然沒有跟著拉回
沒有往上漲
更換又來到重要的長期均線位置
月線
換句話說市場上對整個走勢
就比較騙人是用中線角度
不過今天晚上應該會來這邊測
這邊應該適早會優先守穩的部分
那台灣的ADR的部分
今天的台積線是在尾盤有稍微撐一下
不過還是滿辛苦
是因為這邊的一個前幾次的一個高點
產生一個新的一個下降趨勢線
那各位也可以放進去
它前幾年過這個下降趨勢
換句話說
它現在位置有在這邊恰伏的整理
重點是現在大家要注意
這條叫做黃色的線叫季線
目前計的位置
扣底這個位置
逐漸往上扣
也就是說
台積電ADR如果遲遲沒有往上攻
既線位置就逐漸會往下來下彎
這個對台積電ADR的走勢
就相對會有一些壓力的部分
那我們回到台股
台股我之前遇到 預估過了
長兩個禮拜
好好把握
因為我有把握
可以長兩週
那長完兩週之後
我就沒把握
果然是沒把握
真的就拉回來
拉回這一週
這禮拜是週量4.26兆
量縮價跌
我上次提高過一個雙哀效應
讓整個大盤來到46,500點
我上次有可比提高過
45,000以下或46,000以下
來的機會都可以來得到
因為那個叫做可以來供得到
但是如果真要上去的話
台股真實力的考驗
就在46,500點以上
考驗失敗 拉回
那如果是這樣的話
這波已經失去4萬6在供的機會了
短時間我實在想不出
有什麼樣的效應的部分
更何況現在大家也在等待
下禮拜兩個不確定
一個叫輝達的財報
這次比較屬於個別公司
一個是Jason Hall
全球央行的看法
那尤其這次又是華許的
第一次在全球央行Jason Hall
來發表看法
所以我想這個部分
可能也叫成市場上都在做一個觀望
我們來看一下
這波我為什麼認為說大盤
近期來講的話
我個人認為是45676以上會有壓力
怎麼說呢
我們之前提到過39384
這邊有兩天的1.1兆的
總共2.2兆
在哪邊出現換手
就在這邊
就是我們來看一下
又再來一個
就在這45,000左右
原本應該是這邊買的
這邊賣到給這邊
然後後來一個叫做
剛剛我講的雙哀效應
讓這邊的換手往上供
很巧的這兩天又是1.1兆多
就1.1兆
換句話說這邊賣給這邊
這邊賣給這邊
這邊現在要供的話
你再有一個再來一個1.1兆
看起來今天都已經來到8000以下了如果短時間要1.1兆我實在是比較難想像現在有什麼樣的資金 益助更何況最近的法人也有比較保守一部分
這一波比較弱的原因
我更能認為近期來講的話
是比較觀察的重點是在
美元指數極轉弱
當然美元指數轉弱不到100以上
最主要是日圓的走強
所以日圓走強
市場上考慮的東西就多了
到底要不要趕快還日圓
這個很重要的
尤其各位去看一下
這一波的大盤的走勢
前面這邊叫合理的拉回
因為這邊借太多
這邊的拉回就是跟日圓大幅的升值
那各位還想到
高市預期應該會讓九月份日圓要做升息
換句話說你會發現
台股的走勢現在就跟日圓的走勢
會有一點很相似
所謂說日圓這邊趕快在左扁
市場上的錢又趕快可以跑出來
做這個五本生意
不是五本
小利息的成本的部分
但是這個大盤也不會跌到哪邊去
最好的位置
43,119.7月份的收盤
這邊會有大支撐
所以我個人認為說
先破月線
足底之後再上工
會比較好一點
因為什麼
因為現在45676有壓力
今天收盤盤
你這個位置也差不多不到1%
1%誰要進來
大戶不會進來的
只有什麼
零星的錢才會跑進來
所以各位講大戶不會進來的
因為空間太小了
空間有限
空間太小
所以短時間來講就是
國債的殖利率高
高股息殖利率
最近為什麼那麼強
就是這個原因的部分
好 那我們來看一下
最近有一些個股還是滿強的
之前有講到委屈的紅藤
當然股災還是有在稍微探底
但最近也彎上來了
今天漲停滿表態
所以離當時講已經20%了
這更厲害了
新產本來就是很傳統的避風股
但這一波已經不是避風了
是變標股緩緩往上招
最近的包括中債保
這些相關的常務保險公司都大漲
那這個MACI
總也給我一個肯定
因為至少當時候我看到這個價值
那後來也把它納入 納進去了
那我們看今天的一些市場上
高股息值率率的代表公司來講話
我想在電子公司
最具有代表就是模組的部分
模組廠 記憶體模組
模組我們看一下
你看今天的像舉個例子
模組長的創建
它今年上半年的EPS 46塊
YY 2421 24倍
很恐怖
這個微剛12倍
然後群年19倍
那你看如果以他們
今年的股力來算的話
大概就快有4%到3%
那你要想這是拿去年的成績
今年到上半年都已經倍數增長
所以這個隨便加一個
一年大概就5%以上
絕對一定會有
所以這個威剛你會發現
舉個例子
威剛就很簡單就是
他家公司就是
低檔一定會有個
5%殖利率的保護
因為今年配18塊
明年不可能第18塊
一定會高於19或20或更高
如果這樣的話
低檔有高股息殖利率保護
但是高檔有什麼
層層的套牢
所以這個就是什麼
大跌的時候你可以考慮一下威剛
然後大漲的威剛就不用考慮
因為層層的套牢就住在這邊
但是確實獲利成長非常大
非常好 對
所以我們今天如果比較激動的
那種快速的
例如說今天模組大漲
你看禮拜一模組這邊就不會大漲
就會稍微休息一下
如果你要穩健的
這個部分比較屬於穩健型
這一組叫穩健型
穩健型大概就殖利率5%
本益比20倍以下
然後長期穩健
包括有雅尼 蓮強 燃寶 神機
這邊看起來今年上半年的EPS
YOY也都成長
那神機大概是馬上從衰退變成持平
不過看起來目前本益比都在20倍以下
甚至有些是在10倍以下
好 我們來看一下
今天會講兩家公司
第一家就是講電子公司的倫保好 在伺服器代工裡面雖然是沒有漲多的沒有漲多那為什麼放人保因為它裡面股性就最穩健的這個位置你不是要求積極
你要求穩健
再求什麼 有機會獲利
好 那家公司之前為什麼會比較落後
當然就是相關的AI的步調
稍微慢一點
不過現在大概上次公司有提到過
今年的非PC的部分要佔比較來到四層
然後AI的伺服器要轉強
挑戰每年的三位數
其實它目前它就各位數的部分
所以這塊部分會幫助它的營收
未來會有加分
那事實上營業人
也慢慢有做一個增長的部分
上半年的EPS 1.18
93%
今年EPS我認為有機會挑戰2塊錢
如果按這樣的幅度來算的話
明年大概有機會發放到1塊8
我大概算殖利率5%
然後本益比大概有17倍左右
好 所以我們來看一下股價走勢
哪裡是底部
眼睛看就知道
這裡就是底部了
你最大的風險大概就在這裡了
因為什麼
這是位置
大量位置也在這裡
換句話說
你在這位置就是
等待什麼時候有機會
再做一個所謂的
拉回再往上攻
因為大家的成本都相當
更為這個大幅度在這裡
告訴你 我在這裡撐住
所以你就不用擔心
只是說就是量比較小一點
那最近跌下來的時候
發現還好
股價流拉回幅度也是有限
因為都已經拉回到
原先這邊的起漲點
大概35塊附近
對 所以我覺得這個部分
倒是對穩健型的等人來講
可以考慮
很容易判斷
這個破下去就是要停損
那如果看起來的話
這邊打底那麼久
應該算是夠大的底部了
是
另外一家是雅尼
雅尼這家公司
大家看應該對它
大概就是概念
現在水泥就是營收
是小幅衰退的
也不會大變動
因為他們每年營業
就是差不多這樣子
反正就是跟台泥跟亞泥
大家一起分
加你這些比較小的部分
就一部分
反正就是他們營業
每個人都是固定
差不多700億到800億
不過他的轉投資的
相關的電力事業
還有最近大家看
航運股的育民
他股價也來到相對高
這邊對他有貢獻
你看一下
他今年上半年EPS
已經2.13了
年增將近66%
營業率的長泥
也都是維持在10%左右
今年EPS應該有機會挑戰3.5元
那大概算一算
以今天的股價來看
北比差不多10倍左右
重點是在這裡
各位去看一下
待會你就會知道外資的思考模式
你看它每年都配下2塊多
好穩定喔 每年都配你2塊多
對耶
我們這家公司也算大了
然後如果今年EPS
可以挑戰3.5元的話
我要算今年的發放力的話
大概可以達到2.7元
股息實力達8%
達8%左右
那我們來看一下
好
這個大戶外資在這裡
外資在這裡
那你想
你拿3萬5拿去放銀行
一年才花你多少錢
沒多少錢 1%多
那你現在每年都給你
2000塊錢以上的利息
你用4萬塊你每年5%
拿2000塊都夠
更何況現在還不到4萬塊
換句話說
這些外資的算盤都很清楚了
我放在這邊
放在銀行
也拿不到2%的利息
這邊至少有6%到7%的利率
更何況它不會倒
更何況它還有高淨值的部分
所以這種價值股的公司就是
底部不知道什麼時候
但如果知道它的底部的時候
大家就很清楚了
這叫連線 這叫月線季線
大家的成本都一樣的時候
那就沒有所謂的
太多的套樓賣壓的部分
那原則上短時間這部分的量
慢慢的滾上去
我個人認為說這部分應該是有利於
它未來會往上攻的部分
投資就可以回到非常非常簡單
是
剛剛一看底部
用眼睛看就知道這個也是
用眼睛看
這邊就是越接近30塊
完全殖利率就拉得超級
每年配例2塊錢
每年2塊多 2塊多
對 又不會倒
非常簡單的方式
那樣謝謝鍾總
謝謝趙華